[Music]
gin is a distilled alcoholic spirit
it's flavored primarily with juniper
berries in fact the word gin is believed
to come from genever
the dutch word for juniper it's the base
for many popular mixed drinks such as
the martini
the singapore sling and of course gin
and tonic
this microdistillery produces gin in
small batches
using the slower distillation process
they don't add any sweeteners artificial
flavoring or
coloring at this distillery
everything is done by hand starting with
the main ingredient
juniper berries
then spices are added dried angelica
plant roots
[Music]
coriander seeds
[Music]
lemon peel and cardamom
all these ingredients go into a 90
gallon copper still
a spirit distilled from fermented grain
is already in the still
it's completely tasteless but has an
alcohol content of 95 percent
to lower the alcohol level to 40 percent
they've diluted it with spring water
now they prepare to redistill with the
spices
this gives the spirit its distinct chin
flavor
to do this they slowly heat the bottom
of the still
in about an hour the alcohol boils and
begins to evaporate
they continue distilling for about six
hours constantly monitoring the
temperature
if the temperature reaches 212 degrees
the water will also evaporate
ruining the batch
the alcohol steam rises up and out of
the still through pipes leading to a
chilled stainless steel tank
when the hot steam hits the cold it
condenses back to a liquid
creating gin
[Music]
throughout the distillation process they
take samples to measure the density
and temperature
these readings reflect the current
alcohol level
they adjust the distillation speed as
required to produce a target alcohol
level of 76 percent
[Music]
only the middle of each batch known as
the heart of the distillation is
collected
[Music]
this particular distillery adds another
step they infuse the gin with raw
parsnips
this gives it an earthy flavor and
subtle floral aroma
they peel and slice the parsnips place
them in a tank
then pump in the gin
[Music]
after a couple of days they pump it
through filters on the way to a storage
tank
then they dilute the gin with water to
lower the alcohol level to 43
before bottling the distillery draws
samples for quality control testing
they examine the color the aroma and of
course
the taste there will be slight
variations in flavor
based on the freshness of the parsnips
this micro distillery has no automated
bottling line
they fill the bottles by hand only six
at a time
they cork each bottle individually with
a hand operated press
they apply a plastic sleeve which they
heat shrink tightly over the neck
[Music]
the consumer pulls a small gold tab to
remove the seal and uncork the bottle
[Music]
this hand operated machine labels one
bottle at a time
the machine removes the backing to
expose the adhesive
then presses the label onto the bottle
[Music]
this is a london dry gin meaning it's
made with the traditional ingredients
and contains no added sweeteners or
colorings
this distillation process is how gin was
made before the age of large commercial
[Music]
distilleries
you